foreign
okay good one uh so this is like top
three roast chess memories that I have
this is the game Carlson Howell from
World youth Championship 2002. I needed
to win the last game I was half a point
in front
the most annoying part I remember about
that last round is that on the
Premiership he was playing against
um
an Indonesian player
I think he played the karukan as black
he had an extra pawn and a great
position and then he just collapsed and
I was losing my advantage as well and I
just remember just raging like crazy uh
but uh obviously it's got David a bronze
medal so that's that's a good part let's
go downhill from that wow 19 years ago
and you still remember the game next to
you